Ich kann es nicht fassen, dass
du wirklich "schönschlau" schaust,
so eine Gehirnwäsche.
- Wieso "schönschlau" Gehirnwäsche?
Das ist eine Wissenssendung!
Da werden Alltagsfragen ...
- Siehst du nicht, wie
gehirngewaschen du bist?
Du bist so gehirngewaschen,
du merkst es nicht mal!
* Musik *
Von postfaktisch über Fake-News
bis hin zu alternativen Fakten.
In einer Zeit, in der es
nicht leichter sein könnte,
an Informationen zu kommen,
ist eines sicher:
Kein Fakt kann so überzeugend sein,
dass er eine Meinung
verändern könnte!
Du magst ja Zahlen und Fakten haben,
ich hingegen habe eine Meinung!
Das alles mag
nach einem aktuellen Trend klingen,
aber Wissenschaftlern
ist das Phänomen
der unbeugsamen persönlichen Meinung
seit Jahrzehnten bekannt.
Stell dir vor, du würdest an einer
psychologischen Studie teilnehmen.
Man gibt dir Notizen zu lesen.
Es handelt sich um Abschiedsbriefe,
die Menschen vor ihrem Selbstmord
geschrieben haben sollen.
Bei der Hälfte handelt es sich um
Worte echter Abschiedsbriefe,
die andere Hälfte ist Fake.
Jetzt sollst du beweisen, ob du
ein guter Hobbypsychologe bist,
sollst entscheiden, welche
dieser Briefe echt oder Fake sind.
Du liest den ersten Brief,
entscheidest.
Und siehe da: Du hast recht.
Du liest den zweiten Brief, auch
da hast du ein gutes Gespür, usw.
Stellt sich heraus,
du bist ein echter Pro darin,
echte von falschen Abschiedsbriefen
zu unterscheiden.
Dein Kumpel im Nebenzimmer, der
an derselben Studie teilnimmt,
hat den Dreh nicht so raus.
Er rät fast jedes Mal falsch.
Aber anschließend bekommt ihr
jeweils gesagt,
dass alles nur inszeniert war.
Unabhängig davon, ob du richtig
oder falsch lagst,
hat man die immer nur gesagt,
du lägest richtig.
Und deinem Kumpel hat man immer nur
gesagt, er sei falsch.
Alles also nur Schein.
- Was?
Nachdem man euch
jetzt klar gesagt hat,
dass alles nur manipuliert war,
sollt ihr jetzt
im Nachhinein schätzen,
wie gut ihr tatsächlich
geraten habt.
Über- oder unterdurchschnittlich?
Was denkt ihr, was jetzt passiert?
Die Teilnehmer, denen eine bessere
Performance vorgegaukelt wurde,
schätzten sich als
überdurchschnittlich ein.
Die Teilnehmer, denen Versagen
vorgegaukelt wurde,
schätzten sich als
unterdurchschnittlich ein.
In Wirklichkeit schnitten
beide Teilnehmergruppen
gleich gut oder schlecht ab.
Das bedeutet: wenn man sich
erstmal einen Eindruck
oder eine Meinung gebildet hat,
dann hält man an diesem Eindruck
oder dieser Meinung fest,
auch wenn man im Nachhinein
feststellt, dass es falsch war.
Es ist uns völlig egal!
Das ist nicht die einzige Studie,
etliche kommen zum selben Ergebnis.
Sind wir eigentlich dumm?
"Confirmation Bias"
ist ein menschliches und
sehr gut untersuchtes Phänomen.
"Confirmation Bias"
beschreibt die Tatsache,
dass wir Informationen, die
unser eigenes Weltbild stützen,
prinzipiell als glaubwürdig
und relevant betrachten,
während wir Informationen,
die nicht in unser Weltbild passen,
ignorieren oder als Quatsch abtun.
Eure Facebook-Chronik
ist garantiert eine einzige
"Confirmation Bias"-Blase.
Hier fanden Wissenschaftler
etwas Interessantes heraus.
Informationen, die unserer
eigenen Meinung widersprechen,
führen nicht dazu, dass wir
unsere Meinung überdenken.
Nein, sie führen nur dazu, dass wir
unsere eigene Meinung verhärten.
Da sagt doch jemand tatsächlich
etwas, dem ich nicht zustimme!
Unerhört, was die anderen behaupten!
Alles Lügner!
So schallt es gleichwohl
von allen Seiten.
Als Wissenschaftler
fragt man sich:
Wenn wir so irrational sein können,
warum hat sich diese Eigenschaft
evolutionär durchgesetzt?
Stellt euch vor,
eine Maus würde nicht glauben,
dass Katzen gefährlich sind.
Weil das nur Panikmache ist
von den Ratten.
Und egal, wie viele Mäuse von
anderen Katzen gefressen werden,
diese Maus bliebe
bei ihrer Überzeugung:
Sie würde nicht lange leben!
Und der Mensch?
Forscher glauben, dass diese
irrationale Seite von uns
einen evolutionären Vorteil
gehabt haben muss.
Zur Zeit der Jäger und Sammler
wurde das Leben bereits
von sozialem Zusammenleben,
Zusammenarbeiten,
Zusammenfunktionieren bestimmt.
Die soziale Stellung des
Einzelnen wurde immer wichtiger.
Z.B. möchtest du nicht
dein Leben beim Jagen riskieren,
während die anderen
in der Höhle abhängen.
Die Fähigkeit, andere bei Ausein-
andersetzungen für sich gewinnen,
und dazu gehört auch das Beharren
auf dem eigenen Standpunkt,
war manchmal wichtiger als
rationales Urteilsvermögen.
In Zeiten wie diesen, wo
wir mit Fake-News überflutet werden,
wo rationales Urteilsvermögen
das Allerwichtigste wäre,
hat sich unsere Umwelt
schneller verändert
als die Evolution mithalten kann.
Und so kommt es manchem
vielleicht vor,
als würden wir uns wieder
rückwärts bewegen.
Ok, Mai, was ist jetzt die Lösung?
Die Lösung habe ich nicht!
Aber ich weiß, was sich
immer vorwärts bewegen wird.
Und das ist Wissenschaft
und Forschung.
Die Wissenschaft scheißt
nämlich auf deine Meinung!
Du kannst auf deiner Meinung
beharren, wie du willst:
Solange du keine Daten produzierst,
die Forscher reproduzieren können,
egal, ob sie deiner Meinung
sind oder ob sie dich mögen,
klar gibt es auch Wissenschaftler,
die betrügen und lügen,
solche Menschen gibt es überall.
Aber das Prinzip Wissenschaft
ist möglicherweise das einzige,
was uns
vor der Dummheit retten kann.
Meine Meinung!
Auch wenn schönschlau ein leichtes,
unterhaltsames Format sein soll,
ist es uns wichtig,
dass wir selbst im Alltag Interesse
an der Wissenschaft wecken.
Damit die schlauen jungen Leute da
draußen sich nicht nur für Politik,
sondern auch für
Naturwissenschaften interessieren.
Viel mehr rationales
Urteilsvermögen! Schönschlau!
Für dieses Video habe ich mich
inspirieren lassen
von dem lesenswerten Artikel
aus dem "New Yorker":
"Why facts don't change our minds".
Habe ich unten verlinkt, zusammen
mit wissenschaftl. Studien.
Lasst mich wissen, was ihr denkt:
Beharrt ihr auf eurer Meinung
oder lasst ihr euch auch mal
vom Gegenteil überzeugen?
Schreibt es mir. Bis nächste Woche!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag vom Funk (2017)